the bite administration is dealing with
crisis upon crisis and by agenda is
crumbling progressive and moderate
democrats are blaming each other for
their party's failure it's no wonder
there's a lot of net analysts are
predicting a democratic shellackie in
november but house speaker nancy pelosi
says not to worry she got it covered
i don't agonize i organize and we are
fully intent uh to win this election
nothing less is at stake
in
forget history we're talking about
future
you know laura i want to nancy pelosi
was on george stephanopoulos today and i
don't know if she's suffering from joe
biden disease or mannerism but watch how
she responds if she does on the issue of
inflation go with it let's go with the
sound bite
there has to be a cumulative effect a
cumulative effect and part of the
consequences of all of that investment
in the
infrastructure bill and the rest is that
more people have jobs and and therefore
inflation goes up it's not right with
all the respect in the world for my
friend joe
manchin it's not right to say that what
we're doing is contributing to inflation
because it is exactly the opposite
lord can you please
make some sense out of what she said and
what the democratic programs are doing
to curb inflation last time i checked
7.5 highest in 39 years
yeah the nicest thing i can say about
nancy pelosi is that i guess she changed
her hair and it looks nice enough
that sound bite was absolutely
ridiculous
no one believes anything she's saying by
the way from the fact that she says
she's not worried about the midterm
elections she is petrified the democrats
have been shaking in their boots since
about the second month of biden's
presidency because they've seen it's
just like a plane that you know is gonna
crash it is so bad and you think nancy
that maybe the trillions and trillions
and trillions of dollars that you guys
have spent of money that we don't even
have no one has been able to say how
we're going to pay back all of this
spending you can't just print money
endlessly ask people in venezuela at a
certain point the money itself becomes
uh worthless that the paper it's printed
on is more valuable than the money so
absolutely absurd to hear from her that
they have no fault in what has happened
in our country right now ridiculous
i i agree with you 100 and joey you know
what i think on everyone's mind crime is
the number one issue in this country
among with the federal mandates and what
you have is a democratic party who has
from 2020 have never supported the
police if you listen to nancy pelosi you
get a different argument here she is
here she is again defending the police
cory bush congresswoman from missouri is
saying it's time to defund the police
he's sticking by that you're the speaker
how do you think democrats should
address rising crime well with all the
respect in the world for court push that
is not the position of the democratic
party
joey fox viewers can fc montage of
democrats from the squad even our vice
president calling for not only defunding
the police but supporting criminals
in the last three years creighton if i'm
wrong have you seen any democratic
programs in which they support the
police i think their policy has always
been defund the police and uh support
the criminals how do you see it
you know sometimes our liberal
colleagues in the media can give a
master class on spin they can take
something ball it up wrap it up make it
look like something completely different
and throw it back at you nancy pelosi
cannot that's not what this is listen
you know it's not about defund the
police is some overarching specific
narrative it's about the changes in
people's lives or lack thereof that a
that a a posture towards not supporting
police have created this isn't about
whether or not you fund police it's
about if you have quote unquote bail
reform that lets criminals out of jail
it's about having a 900 limit on theft
before you even think about prosecuting
someone or arresting them it's about
seeing things happen day in and day out
and knowing a part of the reason that's
happening as police officers have to
think twice about risking their lives to
do their job i don't care if you call it
defund the police i don't care if you
what you call it
if you want to if if all you have left
is to argue a single semantic you've
lost and democrats have lost on this
issue and unfortunately that means
americans have lost because democrats
are in charge of the white house right
now
i agree so i mean it's so obvious they
have never supported the police aisha uh
in my opinion i think joe manchin and
kristen cinema have saved the democratic
party in the sense of not going on with
buildback better and once that became a
dead issue they went the progressives
went back after cinema and match it on
the voting right bill in the filibuster
so so why are the democrats why are they
so reluctant to even come to the middle
of the center prior to the midterms
well i'm glad you brought up cinema
mansion because i was going to make the
point if you if you watch what the
democrats have been doing since bill
back better sort of just fell apart into
pieces before the holidays they keep
pivoting right they keep pivoting from
one thing to another and they went from
buildback better to voting rights and
trying to change the filibuster and
trying to put these moderate democrats
on the record and then they turned on
mansion and cinema and they do that
because really when you don't have any
cards left that's the card that you play
you play the cards that you have left
but look forget about congress and
forget about the play-by-plays and the
politics that's going to continue on
until the midterms put that aside and
think about the average person at home
no one cares about inside politics
happening in congress no one cares what
nancy pelosi says no one cares what
mansion says what cinema says at the end
of the day what people what you're
regular americans i'm from the heartland
what they care about are their bills
are their bills going up are the store
shelves full of food my mom tells me
every week i didn't find this at the
store that's what people care about and
if they can't solve those basic issues
then they have a major problem
that's right thank you team hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else